flu can be very deadly for old people
for the very young for pregnant women
and for the immunocompromised so
therefore very vulnerable groups and for
them it's a matter of life and death we
are a group of computer scientists and
statisticians from several different
departments working together with a
common goal of making epidemic
forecasting a reality in 2013 the CDC
launched a predicted influenza season
challenge where they as smugglers to
make forecasts throughout the season of
influenza activity levels this season
the flu epidemic has been very difficult
to forecast and predict not only because
it's been stronger than it's been in
previous years that we have data for
this season followed the shape that all
early seasons do and then it just kept
going up so it really confused our model
I think I've talked to other groups it's
confused their models as well so we not
only have to do forecasting but also
back casting to figure out what do we
think that the value that we get which
was actually slightly off
what was that value actually what was
the true value now casting
algorithmically is also very interesting
trying to find creative ways to figure
out what information is out there one of
our group members but a lot of work to
work with all these different types of
data sources the number of tweets and
I'm related to flu Wikipedia page hits
we actually rely on people's judgment
and aggregate people judgment and
compare that to the performance of the
statistical method well to do that well
you need to have a very good user
interface so we have here the
human-computer interaction Institute we
have to draw on
we already saw with this now casting
system that going down to the state
level and it can improve predictions
have a national level so by modeling
individual metropolitan areas we can do
a better job not just on the
metropolitan areas but also on the
nation as a whole there are many
diseases that would benefit from
forecasting so dengue and terror
diseases stomach bugs certainly
chikungunya and Zika
very big syke as you know has tremendous
human cost knowing in advance where it's
going to hit big is tremendously useful
to governments as they try to to arrest
the the outbreak
how far is gonna go how bad is gonna be
and what's the most effective way of
stopping it